and i source just came forward and
confirmed the mass release of migrants
underway in texas adding that some of
these men have criminal past as our
camera captured this video at the san
antonio airport
meanwhile there is this footage from a
new york airport the end point for some
of the charter flights filled with
migrant children that landed in the dead
of night this past summer and it
features this stunning exchange between
a security officer and a federal
contractor involved in those flights
i get the whole
secrecy and all this [ __ ] but this is
even about my experience yeah
you know what i mean
and why
you know why you know what yeah i know
but why
yeah
no but what's what's the big secret
everybody knows what's happening
the government
josh i mean it really is striking secret
charter flights in the dead of night we
know two million illegal immigrants
coming to our southern border and some
of the statements uh that we just played
are accompanied by others dhs wants
everything to be on the down low so
secretive uh no transparency here what
we don't want to do is attract attention
what we don't want is the media if this
gets out the government is betraying the
american people this is seems like a
cover-up and should republicans take
back the house and the senate there
needs to be some invested investigatory
work looked into this because i believe
we're only scratching the surface here
100 percent cayley and first of all
thank god for fox news because otherwise
i don't think anybody would know
anything about this i mean you know they
were talking about having it get out to
the media i mean look i think the rest
of the media other than fox is basically
complicit in this there's there's no
sort of curiosity whatsoever i must have
missed the the statute that passed the
house and the senate that allowed for
transport of illegal immigrants to
unsuspecting communities across this
country i didn't see that happen i
didn't see the white house put a policy
paper out on that i didn't hear anybody
talk about what that could mean to the
communities where these these illegal
immigrants end up nobody's talked about
it and the reason is they're trying to
keep a secret thank gosh that this thing
has been exposed and we can hopefully
push for some answers kaylee your point
about republicans should they regain
power 100 percent this needs to be at
the top of the list
should be at the top of the list emily
especially because it's at the top of
the list for american voters or at least
a top five issue and most polling but
emily it's just such a double standard
when americans have to take their shoes
off to get on planes as one of the
federal contractors said but these
illegal migrants grab their bag and hop
on a bus
that's exactly right and that's why when
the federal contractor said you know if
this gets out the government is
betraying the american people i argue
they already are they are betraying us
whether or not this gets out and to
josh's point thank goodness yes that our
bill malugin and others from fox news
are on this now just last hour he
reported as you mentioned kaylee that
ice is releasing migrants with extensive
criminal records now the delia nation is
argued by the government as oh well it's
misdemeanors versus felonies but recall
when bambi larson was brutally murdered
by an illegal immigrant he had a rap
sheet that consisted of multiple
misdemeanors that included assault and
drug possession recall the illegal
immigrant in in florida just in october
ernesto morales who killed a
five-year-old girl because he was
driving drunk so on those list of
misdemeanors that include duis that
include assault that what is what
matters is the consequence it is not
inconsequential these misdemeanors what
matters is the pattern that these people
have that is what we are bringing into
our communities and remember it's our
tax dollars to your point kaylee it's
our law enforcement time and resources
that are spent on this incredible shell
game this logistical myriad that the
president has up until now totally
denied and yet
spikes risk to safety in communities in
such a ton of ways
yeah no doubt and this explosive
reporting comes on the heels of bill
mollusion's other reporting of those
migrants those single adult males who
are supposed to be deported by title 42
but instead they're going through an
unmarked office some of them and being
released into the interior bill
mollusion out with some new reporting he
spoke to an immigration custom
enforcement ero that's an enforcement
and removal operations officer that
officer was so peeved by what ice put
out their statement in response to that
reporting that he came forward to bill
malugen he said this this is striking
harris we have just scratched the
surface and that these mass releases
have been happening discreetly since
february he goes on to say imagine going
to the office to make phone calls all
day to coordinate travel for someone who
just came in illegally some of them with
criminal records including assault dui
drug possession and a legal re-entry
harris so you have this one cover-up at
the airport in new york you got this
other one where we're told we're just
scratching the surface down in
brownsville look i agree with emily when
she says it doesn't matter whether we
know it or not the law is being broken
and yes we should know it because this
current administration promised to be
the most transparent in history
so it's great to know it and fox is
doing its job as josh has pointed out we
are doing the job the important job of
taking the facts to the american people
as often as we can find them and put
them on the screen and tell you about
them but in the meantime who's watching
out for the law
because that's really at the heart of
this
and you know if you look at what's
happening with these criminals now and
they are criminals i mean democrats are
trying to move the line on well if you
come here illegally you haven't really
committed a crime but yes you have
because that law is already on the books
now you can policy your way through it
or you could just pretend like the law
doesn't exist which apparently is what
they're doing according to the attorney
general down in arizona brnovich who
joined me last hour you can pretend like
you don't see that or that we don't see
that the law is there
but the fact of the matter is they broke
the law when they came here illegally
and then stayed beyond that
no matter what you want to do with with
your heart and mind about the issue that
is the law you can change the law but
they haven't done that yet
so we should be concerned about that or
this will continue i went to brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now